this is an issue that we have to address
because
the national anthem controversy returned
in the aftermath of the killing of
george floyd and everyone connected to
the nfl said their peace about it except
the guy who always has something to say
about everything and that's jerry jones
so for the first time since the issue
came back to the front burner even
though it's not currently on the front
burner the pandemic is jerry jones
addressed it here he is from yesterday
talking about his position on the anthem
and we know all along that his position
has been thou shalt stand here he is
talking about what may be a different
view moving forward
so we all understand and everybody
understands where i stand with the flag
but everybody also understands where i
stand on backing
our players the dallas cowboy players
the key word
is a word called grace
grace
that was then two years ago this is now
we have had very very sensitive times
i don't need to share that we're also
embroiled in a very other
oh a sensitive time with the challenge
and the war literally were on with the
virus
these are very sensitive times
i have nothing to prove as far as where
i'm standing with the flag and where the
cowboys stand i have nothing to prove
regarding my my players and my support
of our players
what i do want to show and want us all
to be a part of is a word called grace
grace
not only grace in our actions but grace
and our understanding where they're
coming from
i want our players to understand the
perception
and where they're coming from regarding
the flag and the sensitivity there and
the many memories there
and i want our fans to understand and
better do because of what's going on
over the last few months and want them
to understand where our players are
coming from there and they do not feel
like that the ones that want to
but basically do that
kneel they do not feel like they're
dishonoring the flag i'm going to have
grace
i've had grace many of you have written
and criticized me for having too much
grace
and understanding regarding our players
and i probably have
and i'm going to have grace regarding
the people that are sensitive about our
flag somewhere in between there is the
weeks as we get together with our team
as we discuss with the team somewhere in
between there is how we're going to
handle it
well there's a lot of
a lot of reminders there of the seinfeld
episode when they were trying to
determine whether or not extended elaine
had grace but uh there's a needle
that jerry jones is trying to thread
here that i think is impossible
um and he he didn't show his hand at all
i i just think that his desire was to
get us all to accept that whatever he
does chris his intentions
are pure he's acting with grace we may
not agree with the ultimate actions but
he's coming from a place of grace where
he's trying to get it right and
in a weird sort of way apologizing in
advance if he doesn't
well yeah he's he's playing both sides a
little bit okay that's fine
i got no issue with that first off i'm
glad to hear him talk about it in
general you know hey that's the one
thing we talked about through the spring
and a few times just you know where is
jerry jones because i think jerry jones
is one of those voices in the nfl that
when he talks people listen and
especially when it's about important nfl
subjects he could kind of ease the
stress level of everybody in the nfl so
i'm glad to hear him come out and say
something now you know two things i know
about jerry jones i mean he loves
america he's mr you know mr america and
i really love that about him and respect
that about him so we know that he's got
great pride in our country you know when
it comes to players hey would i have
liked him to come out and said something
about black lives matter and the
pandemic you know two three months ago
certainly but
i can't sit here and and tell you that
jerry jones you know jerry jones i think
he could go down in history as being
like the most player friendly loved
owner in the history of the sport i mean
his players love him all of them
ex-players you see michael irvin in his
box emmitt smith they're all there i
don't know if they're on the payroll
maybe they are hopefully they are that's
what kind of guy he seems to be
he always takes care of his players his
players love him you never really hear a
player say much negative about him over
all these years really nothing so his
actions do speak loud louder than any of
the words that he might not have said
and i respect him for that and the last
thing i'll say to mike with this is
i like i mean
our country right now it's it's right or
left it's right or wrong there's there
is no middle and it's i think a little
refreshing to go hey
you know this side how about we move
over and respect this side and this side
you move over and we can meet somewhere
in the middle i think he's trying to
give that type of message which i can
get behind i don't know i liked his
whole everything he said yesterday i had
no problem with it well yeah because one
of the challenges now is when people
choose to stand for the anthem there's a
sense that they're getting bullied into
not standing everybody needs to make
their own choice about what they're
going to do
and it would be nice if both sides
respect
whatever yes everyone chooses to do
exactly and that's a that's a
that's a shift if jerry jones lands in
that spot yeah where he says
i want my players and my coaches to make
their own decisions and whatever they
decide to do i will respect it i will
not tell them anything differently it
will not be held against them that's a
break because he was at the forefront of
thou shalt stand toes on the line this
is the way the cowboys do it and it's
always been done that way we showed the
b-roll of the kneeling that was the
gesture prior to the anthem that monday
night game from a few years ago when the
marshall hit full boyle for the first
time right he joined the players and
they took a knee and then stood up
uh so it seems like
during this period of silence there has
been some reflection and if nothing else
an effort maybe with the help of a pr
specialist or two to craft a message
that will
placate as many people as possible or
minimize the chances that he's going to
have somebody ridiculously upset with
him and on that point he was asked about
being called out by a couple of players
on the team newcomers to the cowboys
gerald mccoy and don terry poe a couple
of defensive linemen they wanted him to
speak up in the aftermath of the
protests that occurred following george
floyd's murder here's what jerry said on
why he didn't speak through those many
summer weeks
as you guys know
you don't expect me to just because you
say let's hear from you jerry you don't
expect me to pop up and hear from me do
you
i know you don't and so i'm that's not
the way it works
uh am i interested in what any player am
i interested in what any of our media am
i interested in what everybody has to
say about any issue you bet and i have
rabbit ears i really do
and so having said that i am listening
well look you never have to say let's
see what jerry thinks about something
because before you get a chance to
articulate that thought he's already
said what he's got to say that's what
made this so jarring he doesn't need an
engraved invitation to speak he just
speaks it's out there if there's
something to talk about he talks about
it that's what made this episode so
strange
not that he didn't answer the call to
speak right it said he didn't speak on
his own because he always does speak on
his own without anyone having to ask him
to chris well yeah you're you're right
he's one of the most vocal owners we've
ever seen you know and from that
standpoint and certainly welcomes press
conferences and things like that i think
you're right that's what it was jarring
but you know as i sat there and watched
you know the press conference yesterday
uh and just thought about it a little
more too
you know it the the the platform to do
or say those things wasn't there
necessarily there this year i mean
certainly he could have called and said
hey i'm jerry jones i'm having a press
conference and everybody would have
zoomed in and listened but really more
times than not when we see jerry jones
talk it's after a game it's after
practice it's football has provided him
to be around and the media oh hey yeah
all media i'll talk to you guys in a
little later and you know you crowd
around me and ask me whatever you want
you know that didn't happen so i guess
he didn't feel the need to call a press
conference and do that i mean that's the
only thing i can think of or defending
him in this process because you're right
more times than not you know jerry's
gonna let it be known what he thinks
what's going on in the nfl and what the
nfl should do
it's funny how much time we spend trying
to defend really really rich people with
250 million dollar boats but sometimes
we just do that because we identify
the team the league with them i need to
push back a little bit chris yeah they
had weeks where
dak prescott's future was front and
center and in any other year you're
going to hear from jerry when these
negotiations are happening he'll use the
media any way he can and he does during
the season multiple appearances on 105.3
the fan in dallas it was crickets from
jerry jones throughout the off season
following the draft up until yesterday
he's done nothing he's been completely
underground and again that's his choice
but we need to recognize it is jarring
to juxtapose silent jerry yes with the
jerry we have known ever since the day
he bought the cowboys where he's always
out there front and center with
something to say even when you want him
to stop talking he still keeps talking
so to go from that to nothing at all
from early may through yesterday and
regardless of the reason it's noteworthy
and i think the idea that well the only
reason i didn't talk is because they
wanted me to talk
that that just doesn't make a whole lot
of sense because he always talks
regardless of whether people wanted to
talk or not yeah well no i mean i know
he does i'm just saying it's a different
he doesn't call
you know he's around football people and
then he asks he can't shut his mouth
then when he's around the football and
the media and all that but you're right
mike i got nothing nothing more to say
about that you know he is a guy that i
wish came out from the start
i think he's one of the great leaders of
football i do in a lot of ways and i
think he could have eased the pain of
this whole situation a little sooner
with some of the kind words and things
he said yesterday so it is jarring i'm
not gonna deny it i mean you know i
would the whole time i kept going man i
can't believe we haven't heard from
jerry jones i can't believe we haven't
heard from jerry jones it was shocking
but i guess just it's a weird year and i
guess i'm giving them the benefit of the
doubt for that
or if he had spoken before there was an
opportunity to carefully craft the
message he could have made it worse too
so let's not rule out that possibility
sure maybe it's better that he said
nothing back in june or into early july
because if he had said something then
without the benefit of really thinking
about it and massaging it it may have
made things
worse for him and silence may have been
the smartest path until he got to the
point where he could harmonize these
various competing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports